If you want to see me pretty much just
be miserable,
then stick around to the
end of this video...
Look there might be a
couple that you can find,
But after
sitting through that thing for over two
hours
and it basically just being them
filming the book but it takes place in
2002 instead of 1979, I really don't feel
like it. Like... what do you want from me? I
had to sit through the area code line.
"This is so far from over it's not even in the same area code as over!"
You want me to tell you that the Freddie
Prince Jr. movie that Tommy references
is She's All That,
a movie that I only know
about because of the rumor that M Night
Shyamalan ghost wrote it?
Or you
want me to tell you how they referenced
The Shining with that 'little pig, little
pig' line for no other reason than the
fact that it's a Stephen King movie that
people like?
"Little pigs, little pigs, let me in."
"Not by the hair on your chinny chin chin?"
Well too bad.
I don't have the will to do this right now.
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
"SHUT UP!!!!!!!!!!"